كما قاله احمد هارون القيادي في حزب نظام
عمر البشير الذي دعا السودانيين للالتفاف
حول الجيش قال انه يقف معهم ضد ما سماه
مشروعا اسريا لاختطاف الوطن بدعم اقليمي
ودولي
نخاطبهم اليوم
وبلادنا تشهد احداثا عصيمه
لم تشهدها البلاد على مر تاريخها الحديث
ونؤكد وقوفنا معكم في خندق الوطن لمنع
اختطافه لصالح مشروع اسري مدعوم دوليا
واقليميا
متجاوزين في هذا الموقف كل ما حدث منذ
انقلاب 11 ابريل 2019
حيث اتخذنا وقتها قرارا التاريخي بان
الحفاظ على كيان الوطن مقدما على اي مشروع
سياسي او كيان حزبي او اي مكاسب سياسيه
وانما ابناء وبنات السودان تستحق ان تصام
والا تكون ثمنا لاي نزاع حول السلطه نقول
ذلك باقوى العبارات رغم
وظلم سلطه انقلاب 11 ابريل 2019 بما في
ذلك
[موسيقى]
طلبا لرضا سياسيه واخرى اقليميه ودوليه
ثبت الان انها العدو الاول للشعب السوداني
وللسلطه القائمه ولقوته المسلحه فهي من
تسببت في الحرب الدائره الان
ونفرق تماما ما بين القائمين على تلك
السلطه ومؤسسات الدوله الوطنيه وفي
مقدمتها قواتنا المسلحه التي تقاتل بشرف
وبشجاعه وبساله كالعدي بها دوما وندعو كل
جماهير شعبنا وعضويتنا لمزيد من الالتفاف
حولها ومساندتها واقتراح المبادرات التي
تسند دورها الوطني الذي تقوم به الان